cette semaine nous nous sommes rendus à
l'hôpital des enfants malades pour poser
quelques questions sur la vaccination au
professeur stéphane thieffry monsieur le
professeur quels sont les vaccinations
obligatoires
les validations légalement obligatoire
en france sont la variole la diphtérie
le tétanos
et la tuberculose
ce dernier par le bcg et les facultative
disons plutôt au plus tôt que
facultative recommandable hautement
recommandable de la coqueluche la
poliomyélite
pour une troisième un cas d'espèce ces
problèmes de la pierre aux différents
comment se fait-il que l'on garde le
caractère obligatoire pour des maladies
qui ont pratiquement disparu et bien
cela tient au fait que cette disparition
est une disparition
beaucoup plus apparente que réelle
nous avons en ce moment même d'exemples
de la variole qui sévit dans les pays
voisins il est bien certain que nous
n'avions pas été protégé par une
vaccination à peu près de masse il ya
longtemps que nous subirions l'amène
mais la même épidémie
la disparition de la diphtérie d'une
disparition purement artificiel nous
apprenons encore dans ce service qui
soit des cas un peu particulier
tous les ans trois ou quatre diphtérie
comme il y en avait autrefois et qui
reste mortelle pour le tétanos s'il a
disparu en force et s'il faut encore
déploré quelques milliers de morts par
an en france par tétanos cela aider peut
simplement à la négligence des familles
qui ne fatigue pas
sinon le tétanos serait aussi répandu
qu'il l'était au dernière guerre par
exemple si nous la tuberculose constitué
à quoi particulier et on entend souvent
dire à l'heure actuelle mais pourquoi
vacciner contre la tuberculose puisque
nous pouvons ces liens la guérir été
facilement le rapport c'est un
tuberculeux disparaît c'est non
seulement parce que les deux sont
traitées mais encore parce que les
enfants sont vaccinés et il suffit de se
relâcher une fois de plus pour voir
immédiatement la tuberculose l'avenir le
vo je ne serai que les d'être froide y
at il des contre indications pour l'une
ou l'autre de ces vaccinations et bien
comme toute intervention médicale à la
vaccination
doit être faite abonnés cyr toute
injection dans la peau de l'homme
suppose à l'examen préalable pour savoir
s'il peut le recevoir elian dv quelques
contre indications générales des
vaccinations c'est au médecin définir
elles sont très rigoureusement défini
mais il faut bien dire et deirdre
autrement que de ses contre indications
sont absolument minimes elles comptent
pas numériquement et en pratique tout
enfant bien portant
relativement bien portants peut-être
vacciner bien entendu après contrôle
examen milka yati les accidents maxi
nation il y a deux accidents le maxi
nation mais ils n'ont certainement pas
dit la fréquence et l'ampleur que leur
donne de temps en temps des
qu'ils ont des relations de brest
quelquefois même malheureusement du
carbone le prince
qui sont mal intentionnées et qui drogba
d'autres services on veut comme une des
plus en plus les vaccinations débonnaire
pourquoi eh bien je vais vous dire qu'au
pouvoir vous parler d'un quart des
accidents de vaccination de tous les
résidents de vaccination est une simple
touche pratiquement que la variole et
les incidents de la variole surviennent
surtout juste existe il faut pas les
vielles chez les enfants qui pour la
première fois ont été vaccinées tard
est donc tout à fait recommandable
surtout pour la bergen de faire une
vaccination de bonnaire il pourrait
militer et dont la poliomyélite il en
est exactement de même
avec benzema lundi dans les domaines des
maladies sont d'autant plus grave
qu'elle touche un enfant plus petit nous
en avons un exemple extrêmement précis
pour la poliomyélite qui touche 20% des
cas de poliomyélite surviennent chez des
enfants de moins de deux ans il faut
donc vacciner de bonheur
pour la tuberculose il en est de même
dans les milieux contaminés car la
tuberculose du nourrisson est une chose
terrible dans ses conséquences
immédiates
pour la diphtérie dans les domaines bref
tout concorde pour faire une campagne
extrêmement d'ardents tour des
vaccination précoce
c'est dans ces conditions je relate
patronale milles maximum de sécurité
vaccinale et le maximum de résultat pour
l'ensemble du pays
j'ajoute qu'à l'heure actuelle
ces vaccinations sont devenus très
simplifiée dans la pratique
car nous possédons depuis les
découvertes des grands savants français
les mesures amant nous possédons la
technique des vaccinations associés qui
a fait ses preuves est utilisé dans le
monde entier et qui nous permet de
joindre simultanément à plusieurs
vaccinations ce qui simplifie ould mini
considérablement le travail des médecins
et le travail de la mère de famille s'il
faut tirer une conclusion du petit
entretien que nos avoirs je crois que
c'est en suivant il faut vacciner
il ne faut rien faire pour reporter ces
vaccinations pour les questions du but
diverses
excusez-moi actualité mais terme il faut
plus les mères de famille cours après le
certificat de complaisance il ne faut
pas remettre la vaccination sous des
prétextes divers et soul et shine qui
sont absolument imaginaire
c'est dans ces conditions que une
famille fera ce qu'elle doit faire c'est
à dire son devoir vis à vis enfance et
je souhaite de tout mon coeur que nous
n'ayons pu ce spectacle épouvantable que
nous avons ici d'enfants qui viennent
nourrir hautlence auront pris de
souffrance et de manta plate est en
hausse qui avait vu simplement être
évité car les vaccinations fait-elle
[Musique]